Congressman Tony Gonzalez Congressman we
were texting a few minutes ago you've
been watching our coverage when when you
look at what's happening there again
today after 10 000 people plus came
across the border yesterday what what do
you say to Kareem John Pierre who said
that says that this president has taken
historic action to address this crisis
probably John thank you for having me on
and probably the the most uh pointed uh
response I could tell her is if you
continue down this route you are going
to lose you are going to lose the
election in 2024. the reason I say that
is because this Administration thinks
this crisis is a political problem not a
policy problem so if they want to go
down this route they're going to lose
the White House in the meantime you know
I represent these images that we see
what what the part that they don't
understand is the city of Eagle Pass has
received zero federal dollars from the
White House all this these millions of
dollars are going to New York City and
all these Sanctuary cities are getting
all this money for a handful of migrants
that go there and turn their cities
upside down meanwhile this little town
on on the border of Texas gets
absolutely nothing so it's wrong it's
absolutely wrong but they're not only
are they gonna they're not only they're
hurting real people they're going to
lose the election
well um Congressman thank you very much
for joining us and jumping on the phone
as we continue to look at these pictures
um as Bill malugin just noted that the
mayor of Eagle Pass where we're watching
all these migrants come in is a Democrat
I mean you've got Democrats in New York
they're crying for help singing the
blues they're saying we can't have any
more in this city we can't handle it
governor hokel democrat mayor Adams
Democrat I mean you're hearing from more
within the Democratic party to stop this
will the White House listen
I I hope they do uh you know I'm uh
Eagle Pass Maverick county is is some of
the bluest part of the The District in
which I represent and I'm the only
Republican that has ever won that county
in 200 plus years and and the way these
the people that live there they don't
view it through a red or blue lens they
just want people to help and make this
stop it doesn't take a genius to look at
the images and go this is wrong when you
know the when you when they pull a baby
a lifeless baby out of the water how
does that not break your heart but you
have these folks in the White House just
that think it's a political problem the
other part I'd say is you know this TPS
uh extension that they did for the
Venezuelans all that does is make the
problem worse I've been an advocate a
staunch advocate for legal immigration
for for legal Pathways for people to
come over and work and and do it the
right way and their and the
Administration has been an advocate for
illegal immigration and it impacts
everybody in a negative way and it's
dangerous
you know Congressman when you and I were
texting earlier we were we had been
talking about the economic aspect of
this in terms of New York State wanting
to expedite work permits uh for people
who were in the city illegally because
uh they can't keep up with providing
Social Services on the taxpayer dime so
they've got to let these people they
think uh make a living themselves to
take some of the burden off of the state
and off of the city but the suggestion
from you is that that's just going to
make the situation worse because people
whether it be in the Western Hemisphere
or whether it be on the eastern part of
Africa or the western part of Africa or
other parts of sub-Saharan Africa where
we're seeing migrants come in from say
whoa the cash registers open let's go to
the United States
that that's it John I mean in what
Universe do we live in where people that
break the law and come over illegally
are rewarded and those that are trying
to follow the rules are are punished
what is the solution the solution think
back two years ago in Del Rio the
solution was you enforce the laws that
already on the books if people do not
qualify for Asylum you send them back to
their country of origin until the
administration does that or we're only
going to see this crisis become as bad
as we've ever seen it you wonder how
governments can regain control and start
to tax these people I mean the New York
Post today is writing about the unlawful
economy that is exploding in New York
City right now congressman
no that's exactly right and what about
the border patrol agents uh what you
know a lot of images are on Eagle Pass
but right next to that is Kinney County
and Medina County I was speaking with
the uh the judge and I was speaking with
one of the sheriff the sheriff Randy
Brown from Medina County they're getting
crushed so it's not just this one image
here that that is very powerful but it's
the entire area and you've got everyday
Americans that are going hey what about
us we don't feel safe I did a teletown
hall yesterday in El Paso which is 800
miles away I had a constituent call in
and say hey look they're releasing
people in the street you know I'm a a
veteran and I work for the the police
department I don't feel safe so I I know
these images are in Texas in Texas today
but we're already seeing what's
happening in New York it's it's
California Nets it's it's Chicago it's
it's a small little towns as well we
have to stop this I think part of it
stops with the finger pointing
everyone's to blame but the White House
certainly can't just you know punt the
ball how do we solve this problem we do
it by increasing the number of border
patrol agents and enforcing the loss if
they don't qualify for Asylum send them
back I understand Venezuela we don't
have an agreement with it where is the
state department in this equation where
is secretary blinken instead of talking
about other issues he needs to go to
Venezuela or Columbia and work on an
agreement where maybe they don't go back
to Venezuela but maybe they go back to
maybe they go to Panama or Columbia
Third Country this is how you solve real
problems until they take that level of
of uh interest in this you're only going
to see it get worse and they're going to
get their bus their bus kick in the 2024
election uh Congressman you've been
you've been watching along with us as
we've been following this group of
illegal migrants as they cross the Rio
Grande They crawled underneath the
concertina wire they were apprehended by
the border patrol uh and now they're in
in a an area where they're now being
processed and our Intrepid Hillary
Vaughn who is just fantastic to get bird
dogging Democrats on very touchy issues
got a quote from Debbie Wasserman
Schultz when she asked her about the
situation on the border Congressman your
colleague from Florida said what you see
is different than what happens in
actuality what do you make of that
I mean she is partly right because if
you're on the if you're on the ground
you're you can you can what you don't
see it is you don't see the smells you
don't see the the frustration yeah on on
the border patrol agent's uh faces you
don't see the the dire uh the direness
of the people that are there uh it's all
sad I mean just even looking at the
images you know small little children
running around having to Wade through
the water that's the part that you don't
see so it's actually worse I would say
she's onto something it's actually worse
than what you see on TV not that it's
it's the other way and and Bill's been
covering it fox has done an amazing job
of covering it but when you're on the
ground you cannot unsee some of these
images or some of the smells you know in
some of these facilities
um all right so I guess we should put
that down is don't believe you're lying
eyes because they're not giving you the
full sensory experience
all right
all right Congressman appreciate you
jumping on with us thanks Congressman
appreciate it okay yeah thank you John
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm aimsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis